Let's go through a possible answer together.
We initialize our chart to be the empty mapping,
and I'm going to define a procedure named memofibo.
If we're asked to compute the Nth Fibonacci number, and it's already in the chart,
then we don't do any more work. We are super lazy.
We just look it up in the chart and return that.
Otherwise, we need to both set the chart and return the new value.
So if n < or = to 2, the thing we want to write down in the chart is 1.
Otherwise, we'll figure out the value of the chart by calling ourselves recursively
on n - 1 and n - 2 and adding them together.
In any event, since we set the chart here or here, we'll just return the value in the chart.
Now I've asked us to print out the value of memofibo 24,
and we get the answer that we're expecting.
However, the real proof is in the timing.
Using our timing code once again, I've now put in the code for memofibo instead,
and we're trying to compute memofibo of 25.
How long does it take to do this 100 times?
Oh! Significantly less time!
Remember before it was almost 3 seconds--almost half of our page budget.
Now you can barely detect it--not a tenth of a second, not a hundredth of a second,
but even smaller. This was a phenominal cosmic optimization.
We are so much faster. It is not even funny.